(bright music)
- When I'm running backwards,
it almost feels like I'm flying
because it's such a
different visual perspective,
seeing how far I've gone as
opposed to how far I need to go.
When you're going backwards
you can really just
take a step back, literally,
and enjoy what you're doing.
(playful music)
Hi, I'm Aaron Yoder.
I'm a backwards runner.
I have the world record for
the fastest mile ran backwards.
My fastest backwards mile time is
five minutes and 54 seconds.
I've been running forward
for over 20 years.
I started running competitively
when I was in elementary school,
and then ran on scholarship
during my early twenties.
I ran so much that I
sustained a knee injury.
My doctor told me to stop running,
and I really didn't wanna stop,
so I knew I had to make some sorta change.
(upbeat music)
Retro running or
backwards running is where
you're literally just running in reverse,
and there's no impact on my knee.
I run backwards everywhere.
I run backwards on the treadmill,
I run backwards on the track,
and also out on country roads.
Backwards running feels great on my knee
I don't feel anything,
which is a reason why I really enjoy it.
Stay tall, knee up.
There we go.
Stand up, good job.
When I'm coaching my track team,
I occasionally have them run backwards
as to enhance and diversify
their training workouts.
Onward and upward, good job.
Way to go, good warm up there.
There's more backwards runners out there
than one would think.
There are hundreds, if
not thousands, of people
that decide to run in reverse.
The last World Championships there were
over 20 countries represented
and close to 200 athletes.
Backwards running has
allowed me to see things
in a little bit different perspective.
In a world where everyone goes forward
and I'm going backwards,
it's really allowed me
to just get back to
competing against myself
and not be so concerned
when other people are doing it,
and I found great
gratification in the fact that
I'm just competing against my own shadow.
(bright music)